Film Courage: It's one for courage get a take 1 scene
1 scene 1 take 1
Andrew H and house intuition the house
everybody at film courage my name is
Andrew and yes this is a 1981 DeLorean
behind me this is my DeLorean and you
can rent it at car of dreams calm today
we're going to look over Back to the
Future and I'm going to be watching it
with you guys and we're gonna look at it
as a screenwriter would and I'm gonna be
talking about the four different
conflicts that are in the movie and how
they all get juggled in it so without
further ado let's start the movie
all right just so you know we're not
going to have the movie on the screen so
sync up your DVDs and go on three two
one go all right so you should be seeing
the old universal logo MCA company so
something that I wanted to want you to
think about is want you to ask yourself
what is the definition of conflict to
you
and to me the comp the definition is
technical definition is you have a main
character or any character who wants
something wants a goal and there's some
sort of opposing force some sort of
opposition usually in the in the form of
another character that is preventing
that person from that goal and usually
there's some sort of consequence or
something at stake with that go that
goes very important and there's like a
downside and not achieving that goal so
that's the technical definition but the
easier way to think of conflict is
thinking of it in terms of problems you
see a problem that's conflict and for
every problem there's a solution so
we're going to be going through that
here we're going to be going through
problems and solutions and this film has
many so first we're actually going to be
using post-its there's there's four main
conflicts that are present in this film
one is the death of Doc and we're gonna
be representing the death of Doc with
this green post-it the second one is
Marty getting stuck in the past that's
gonna be represented by this blue
post-it and the next one is Biff Biff is
the main act antagonist and he is going
to be getting the way of a lot of things
so we're to represent his presence and
his all the problems he creates with
this yellow post-it and the final one is
probably the biggest one or one of the
bigger ones
so I'm already needing to hook up his
parents to in order to stay alive and
we're gonna use this pink post-it to
represent that so if you watch this
opening you'll notice that there's
actually not much going on it's really
like a slow reveal where we're starting
to learn a little bit about you know
Doc's character we don't even see him
but we learned that you know his mansion
was destroyed and then the second thing
that we learned is that there's
plutonium and it was stolen and you see
that on the TV and in two seconds here
to see the skateboard hitting the
plutonium that's just like a little
tease because because there's not much
going on here other than set up for the
first 20 minutes it's just a little
tease to let the note the audience know
that that there is something kind of
brewing a little bit so I'm gonna write
down that we're setting up the stolen
plutonium and it's coming up right here
so the plutonium is stolen and it's the
same plutonium that we heard about it on
the TV and we see a skateboard tooth we
see two worlds come together sort of
thing right do we know why Doc's mansion
was destroyed by developers what
happened um I don't think we know why I
mean I think it's just that he he was
rich and he put all his savings into
creating the time machine
interesting he built it in a garage so
everything here is kind of a slower
reveal we don't even you know the
filmmaker is you know Robert Zemeckis is
doing a really good job of just not
giving you everything he's not showing
you that even showing you Marty's face
like you see right here you see the back
of his head and you don't even get to
see him in the beginning you saw his
legs which weren't even Michael J Fox
his legs was a-standin right yeah they
didn't have Michael J Fox for that you
know for that long so they had to you
know they had to use whatever they could
plus you don't even know whose place
this is at first right right you don't
really know you're just trying to put
the pieces together and you're and
you're just seeing that and here we we
see Marty McFly he's got the sunglasses
and he takes them off right here so that
is our main hero so for the rest of this
there's a lot here that just sets up
Marty's life so I'm gonna use the purple
post-it for that and I'm just gonna
write that we're setting up Marty's life
and there's not you know there's not
much going on there's not I mean there's
not many problems that you're sure he's
late for school but that's you know
who cares I mean it's just he's just
late for one day he doesn't make them
you know the audition after that but you
know it's not the end of the world so
I'm not not a lot of problems are going
on in the beginning and they're just
just a bunch of setup and a little bit
of teasing let's try to get you
interested that's actually the purpose
of that plutonium but for this I'm just
gonna put down that we're setting up
Marty's life and that he's basically
this really cool guy who you know
skateboards behind cars and we learned
that he's a guitarist and that he's laid
all the time he's got a girlfriend and
eventually we learned that he wants that
you know 4x4 in that truck but right
here power love by Huey Lewis classic
plus we see the sort of eccentric world
of doc but we don't totally know whose
place it is but all the clocks and then
right his little mechanism for the
morning routine with the toaster and
everything right right he he definitely
has personality and is not even there is
character I mean and yeah and so we're
kind of you know this is all just to
establish character and that's really
important too you know you can have a
character that's in conflict but
sometimes the audience or you know the
audience really needs to be invested in
that character to care about someone in
conflict I mean you know it's the
difference between seeing a total
stranger getting to a fight at a you
know restaurant versus like you know
your best friend or something you know
it's just a little your focus a little
bit more on someone that you really care
about so here we're setting up we set up
that he's he's a cool guy he's always
late rides a skateboard and now we were
introducing him to Jennifer and also
Strickland right here but yeah Jennifer
is really just um she her purpose in the
story is really just to serve as the
stakes for the story you know he
he can't really live a life in 1955
because you know he says he's has he has
a girlfriend here he really cares about
he really wants to see her you know
maybe he if he didn't maybe he could
kind of be okay with living with his you
know family you know and they're younger
or whatever but no he's got something at
stake he's got something you know in
1985 that he really cares about that's
why he really wants to get back to 1985
and it also sets up Strickland as sort
of this supposedly good force but he
seems to always be busting someone's
chops who's not really that bad but
right getting them in trouble for some
reason right so he's definitely you know
a tough principal but he's also you know
what as as much of a jerky as he is he's
also right because he warns him about
Doc Brown and gives this gives doc the
doc character a little more mystery
we're like why is he all dangerous
what's going on but he's right about doc
doc his Doc's
you know put him in front of a moving
car you know later later on in the movie
when he shows them you know the DeLorean
and yes here we have Huey looses a cameo
that's great
and actually if you know load trivia is
that yeah there you see mark Michael J
Fox is a guitar instructor was was over
there he's the guy who developed in with
the guitar like Michael J Fox already
knew how to play guitar he just you know
he was playing along with the instructor
are you see the Goldie Wilson truck
right there
yeah I always wanted a jacket like this
but I really have
yeah these jackets are hard to find
actually some of these are like this
whole outfit sometime like the 501 yeah
this is this red vest was kind of hard
oh yeah Michael J Fox checking out the
women there uh-oh is there a meme about
that right now
I don't know like distracted boyfriend I
think anyway sorry I actually had a big
crush on them Claudia Wells yeah I guess
and I met her in person I kinda made a
fool of myself oh no what'd you do no I
was at her store and then I I was like
she's like do you need any help and I
was like yeah no I'm fine I'm you know
I'm over in this area I'm just looking
at these clothes I was like a giant wall
nothing was there oh wow so there we
have the four by four that Marty wants
right and we're about to get to you know
there you go we have the clock tower in
the background we're about to get some
setup on that oh they're so cute very
cute
he's actually a lot of exposition in
this you know first 20 or 25 minutes and
a lot of that a lot of writers are
always concerned about how to hide that
in you know how to make it not be boring
and this is one of the ways is that kind
of disguise in a joke this is what
they're doing right here you know this
woman that's kind of annoying them what
the activists alright so I'm gonna use
blue because this represents the setup
for from already being stuck in time
what a gentleman is oh I remember that
cars like the AMC 80s car Hornet or
something oh gosh I remember seeing
those it was almost like a station wagon
that was like big tires on it yeah a lot
of great cars and all these cars are
classics now where was this shot is this
on the Warner Brothers lot I think some
of this was on yeah this is all like a
set like a giant set that they met they
converted you know for the 50s and then
they after they made it in the 50s
theaters trashed it for the 80s look so
then we saw the clock tower information
like the yeah still why are we know that
about the clock tower
and we got another setup seen so I said
that the conflict of Biff getting in the
way it's you know we revisit that
throughout the story and this is our
first introduction to that you see
Thomas Wilson just really you know
controlling Crispin Glover some
character
I love Crispin Glover Ennis yeah he's
really easy great I think the director
had to kind of key would do some crazy
stuff I heard and enough work to kind of
like tone him down a little bit I did
the same thing so Biff bullies the dad
once he wants money for the beer that
was spilled on us jacket right he
totally messed up the car which sucks
for Marty and yeah we just see grabbing
on the tie he's the infamous hello McFly
right right and so of course come into
play later in 1955 and he still can't
stand up to him so the dynamics are set
up right yeah his dad is a total
pushover pushover nice guy but just
pushover and actually right after the
scene you'll see the dad actually has
some he'll be eating like peanut brittle
and there was actually a deleted scene
where he a neighbor comes in like makes
the dad makes Crispin Glover buy some
peanut brittle for it you know I guess
the daughter was selling some peanut
brittle and he just gets like bullied
into it but we don't really need that
because we already see him getting
bullied by my Biff it doesn't really add
anything new so that's why they kind of
like deleted it and got rid of it it's
redundant if you have anything you know
as a writer if you have anything that
that's not being that's not new you
might want to consider deleting it you
don't want to be you know repeating
something over and over again for the
audience you know interesting to see the
choices made in the Edit room you know
why that scene should have say it or
didn't stay right right
it's popcorn okay great
get your drink or you're good okay
little bubble oh I'm good friendly thank
you though maybe in a little bit all
right so here's a peanut-brittle scene
they totally cut so they totally that
scene that's where the scene was and
there's just a lot of setup here a lot
of exposition the writer was saying but
sometimes you try to hide exposition and
sometimes you just gotta let people just
say it so it was gonna be a joke here
about uncle Joey right
that's disguising a joke but later on
Lorraine kind of says certain things
that just says a bunch exposition
exposition about how they met sometimes
you just got to get that out of the way
you know you can see too in her sort of
demeanor that she's very blase and right
kind of beaten down and but you don't
know quite what what's going on just yet
right you know you know you see some
subtle things like she's drinking she
doesn't really look that healthy you
know mm-hmm you see
Marty's brother you know has kind of a
crummy job
everybody knows who that is right that's
Jimmy Olsen from the Superman movies oh
okay
and that's Wendy Jo Sperber right Wendy
Jo Sperber his character she can't meet
a boy hmm of course this will come back
later and interesting too this is where
the mom is sort of doubtful of women
that chase after men right then you'll
come to see that that really her and
she's sort of lamenting her yeah I think
the writers were wondering you know if
they went to school with their parents
you know what would they like them and
would any of those things that they told
them they'd be true like you know I had
to hike you know 15 miles to school when
I was your age and stuff and we see that
actually it's quite the opposite hmm and
then I saw a behind the scenes all the
you know prosthetics and things they did
to make Lea Thompson look older right
it's fascinating yeah it's pretty
convincing here I mean mm-hmm yeah they
do they've nowadays they would just have
CGI
you know CGI the makeup on but you can
see it in their demeanor as well they
seem more mature right and I guess I
just learned that Eric Stoltz was
supposedly casas Eric Stoltz was yeah
Eric Stoltz was cast an executive wanted
Eric Stoltz in there and they wanted
Michael J Fox there are some scheduling
issues so they got Eric Stoltz and yeah
he didn't you know they had to make a
drastic decision at the end you know all
right you know in the middle of it so
they cut him
so that one scene was the man from space
honeymooners episode that was the that
did premiere in nights 55 and a lot of
people don't notice but the original
title or the title that one of the
executives wanted was spaceman from
Pluto which was a terrible title he
didn't like back to the future at all
and I think it was I wonder if it's
because of that episode you know the you
know honeymooners episode but they they
eventually I think Steven Spielberg
wrote back to that executive and was
like oh thanks for the joke you know and
they knew that he would be too proud to
actually say oh I was real note you know
and it's just the North Ridge Mall sorry
this is a twenty Hills Mall ah okay no
industry I think I've been there a lot
of it back to the future events and they
do yeah I one of the screenings that I
saw was actually bombed this parking lot
right here so going back to that I
should actually say that all that info
we're going to write down as setup for
the information on the family so you
know all that she was talking about
about the enchantment under the sea
dance and what were you doing bird
watching all that stuff you know can't
find a boy the sister can't find a
boyfriend that's all information on the
family I heard here it is beautiful car
of my dreams part of many people's
dreams 1981 DeLorean dmc-12
and helmet now remain oh they're only
they're only the nine thousand that were
made
only about 6500 exist today huh I got
one of them selves yeah and yours is
beautiful so this is all I'm gonna label
this with the blue again this is all set
up on Marty going you know being stuck
in in 1955 that conflict this is the
introduction of the time machine
this is in the middle of the night right
in the middle of the night this meeting
doc and he's a filmmaker this was one of
the first things that Michael J Fox shot
once he got the role uh-huh
wasn't he doing family ties at the same
time yeah he was doing uh he had some
scheduling conflicts and finally he
really wanted to be in a movie and they
could they can make it work but only if
he worked on both family ties and and
back to the future that's a lot so you
got like no sleep during it okay and
there's doc with his yeah and the
original script it was actually a a
monkey I'm not a DeLorean
the DeLorean part kind of came in last
minute I think they were first thinking
about a refrigerator and then they
realized if you want to do a time
machine you got to make it mobile you
know yeah I don't know how that would
have worked with a refrigerator because
he's traveling it like 80 was at 88
miles an hour or something right
catch
love the old camera there it's
interesting relationship dynamics sorry
between a doc and Marty - right they
don't actually get into it about how
they know each other but I don't think
it really matters they just um Marty is
a cool guy Doc's really eccentric you
know of course they know each other
right yeah you know of course he helped
him with his experiments you know at
four in the morning but you know what
Strickland was right this guy is really
dangerous I mean he puts him in front of
a moving car right there
oh you know I mean what if it doesn't go
back in time you know yeah wow that's
cool sparks there we go back inside
there we go and from his shot he's
realizing it's worked there was a the
filmmakers screened this in from a test
audience that knew so little they didn't
know anything about the movie that when
they first saw this they thought that
they had just like disintegrated the dog
there's like a little bit of a nervous
nervousness in the air right I could see
why right and is the dog going back into
1955 Raul the dogs going one minute into
the future a one minute so yeah they'll
be seeing a dog okay shortly
that's good always got to make sure the
dog or the cat is okay yeah they're a
lot of changes that were made in the
script
the original script actually had the did
not have the Clocktower scene in it it
had the there was like this big nuclear
reaction nuclear test site seeing that
was at the end and actually the
beginning part with the clocks was
actually not in the original script
either it was it was Marty in science
class learning about nuclear reactions
so you know you got to be you got to be
open to
changes as a screenwriter you know they
decided to make the do the Clocktower
sequence because it was it was a lot
cheaper and it tied back into the story
better in yeah and the dog is okay right
is that dry ice yeah that's a wifey I
think yeah that's liquid liquid nitrogen
perfect timing by the way we're in a
garage so someone in a really nice
Porsche just started up liquid nitrogen
huh and the filmmaker said that this was
such a pain to shoot because the liquid
nitrogen would get all everywhere I
would you know that they only they got
rid of it for the once they got mr.
fusion they're like whatever mr. fusion
fixes this problem you know this is like
you know you don't see it again in any
other movie or any other city in the
sequel's you know I could see how that
we really just thought would take so
long to get right all that right and the
dogs great so good I mean we're still
you know about 24 and a half minutes in
okay and not much has happened I mean we
did see you know Einstein go back in
time but the experiment went well I mean
there's no real big problem there's no
big conflict and this this is still
we're still setting up the time machine
and it's not really a save the cat
moment but it's a moment where you know
oh he's okay the dogs all right so right
we're great and they don't good you know
they don't do this scene in the
beginning they don't tell you everything
first they kind of make you question
what you know what what just happened
and then he's telling he's giving you
the answer right now you know I mean
that's how you kind of tease the
audience as a writer or as a filmmaker
you know all right now why did they
choose 1955 because he wants to meet the
parents right right I think they wanted
the 1950s was when was like the age of
the teenager and they also wanted Marty
to go back and invent rock and roll
that just kind of worked out when they
when they wrote the script and I think
around then it was still 1955 so it just
so happened to be 30 years exactly but
yeah that that's that was the age of the
teenager and you know it's a good look a
good time to be in you know Chuck Berry
and I was right
so all this that doc is saying right now
this is all exposition again and
sometimes you just have to just let it
out it's good performance here yeah
we already you know we're already
intrigued enough to be you know to to
listen to this a not get bored really
saw that this is a time machine we're
interested
now let's hear more about what doc has
to say you know and he's eccentric but
he's not where your Freight afraid of
him he's there's a like a trust factor
you can trust him there is a trust and
now he's talking about the plutonium
which could be very important mm-hmm
it's gonna lead us to a first big
problem the plutonium part scared me as
a kid was freaked out by right it's very
scary the music and everything you just
hear it from the music you know when it
comes in
how long will this was the shoot I just
don't know but I know that it took him a
long time to get me there they're trying
to make it a maid for a while like many
many years no they thought it was and
then they shot it but then they had to
redo it because they recast you know the
lead role was tough I thought they'd
give Spielberg one more chance
actually Spielberg was like the only one
that was actually interested in the
movie they took it to all these
different Studios everybody thought it
was it wasn't raunchy enough because all
the top teen movies were all raunchy
comedies like Porky's right right and
then except for Disney who thought it
was like too dirty with the princess
right or at least they saw it that way
Yeah right right right
and then I think they were freaked out
by didn't they think something else is
witchcraft or something or maybe I'm
just I don't know about that okay sure
yeah wasn't it wasn't PG enough and
there was little doors doors open up so
fast the DeLorean is such a great you
know I'm glad they chose the DeLorean
because it's such a unique car how
everything's designed the stainless
steel and engine in the back go wing
doors you know I remember being a kid in
my mom telling me about the DeLorean how
it was like this big failure and it was
being shown at a local shopping center
really it was a big deal at that time so
here's our first major problem aha who's
this big post it and this Sharpie you
know we had a 30 minute mark here uh
yeah almost almost 30 okay
aha here's the scene that totally
freaked me out as a kid right you just
hear from the music and then of course
sound effects and everything scene also
makes me look cringe a little bit you
know at the depiction but it's very
scary I mean I think I had a bad dream
about it it's it's pretty terrifying
most the movies so tame so they want the
plutonium is that right well he screwed
them on the plutonium deal he didn't
build them the bomb that they wanted now
he's just died so doc just got killed
right I wonder how this would be
perceived in today's today's world just
because it'd be interesting at that time
it was one of more new to show all this
but this is the only like major serious
part so
if you see we're also going to write in
blue that you know there's a big problem
that Marty is now in danger so this is a
big problem that's going on right now
and there's a solution for that it's
going to yield another problem so 30
minute mark this is where the true
conflict begins so I'll talk about that
in a bit but that's that's more
three-act structure and if you're a
writer you should know about three-act
structure but I think the first thing
you should know is that it doesn't
always work with every film it's not
screenwriting religion but this film it
does fit in very nicely so obviously you
know the first act is him in 1985 second
act is in 1955 and then 1985 when he
gets back is the third act but I like to
look at it this film in terms of how it
juggles it's for conflicts okay so we
see right here he goes he hits the gas
solution Marty escapes with the car to
get rid of that problem and now he's
traveling through time this is the
scarecrow scene right
so this isn't another this is another
problem that he's got that has the same
solution so he's you know before he was
in danger
and he uses the car to escape this
family puts him in danger again and he
uses the car to escape so I think they
said what the Scarecrow seemed to they
did that on the soundstage or like a not
sound stage but they it wasn't actually
moving they kind of just really
okay this DeLorean actually one of the
reasons why they they did use it is
because not only did they want the time
machine to be mobile but they wanted it
to be here in this for this joke right
here where they they think it's a
spaceship totally freaked out yeah right
and he's in this right he's this zoo and
the animals are not freaked out so I'm
not gonna write it again but it's the
same thing
Marty's in danger and he escapes with
the car you'll see if he actually gets
shot that's the end of our movie so it's
good that they missed great physical
acting - oh my god Mike when a fox is
actually really a really good physical
actor but it's really would like kind of
subtle well they said he was very
reactive and that's what they loved
about right and they needed someone that
would just react to everything right you
definitely seem reacting to Biff right
he and he was you know really
sleep-deprived during this so he just
had to go all on instinct you know and
but I think it really helped his
performance he fixed that they got a
station wagon with a bed in it for him
to sleep in her it would just take him
to set in it and then take him back
probably yeah you shouldn't be driving
on three hours of sleep yeah
so back at the mall you saw that he ran
over that tree arted the ran over that
pine and of course that will come later
in the film it's Twin Pines mall - Lone
Pine mall so he's already changing
history little subtle things that kind
of tie in right little markers
and we got a realization of another
problem here of the the big problem is
that he's uh he's in 1955 this is not
this is not his home look at that old
car nice couple for a Sunday Drive
totally freaked out so here it is stuck
in 1955 and right there
he's got no plutonium no way to come
back so he hires the DeLorean mm-hmm
it makes it so easy to push is it a
light car it seems like it'd be a heavy
car it's pretty heavy car is it yeah it
seems like I've never pushed it so
that's good okay I don't know the nice
Ronald Reagan plug there oh yeah
Ronald Reagan actually saw the movie and
he really enjoyed it
he there's a joke later when Marty goes
and meets meets doc you know about about
the president United States and yeah he
actually I think it was in a State of
the Union Union address he he mentioned
the film you know he referenced the film
so he's a big fan so yeah we're just
kind of taking it all in right here see
the clock tower in the back right and
it's such a big problem that I mean the
filmmakers are kind of you know just
letting you experience it you know I
mean if you're if you're trapped in the
past I mean you might as well see you
know every shot is like kind of like a
nightmare because everything looks
different and clock tower works now he's
wearing the outfit you're wearing which
it's modern and those you know for him
but right it looks like a space outfit
right for those everybody thinks he's a
you know it's a life preserver
well we don't get confirmation until
right and in this moment right here oh
and then we yeah we have reference to
politicians saying the same thing as
Goldie Wilson
you can tell that the clothing is
different right and you just hear from
the music that's a big problem I'm in
1955 but for every problem there's a
solution but we're not there yet we
haven't provided the audience with that
yet he's about to enter he enters or the
Internet okay so this is like there's
this is like where the cool kids hang
out right this is actually a said it's
one of the only interior sets you know
where you can actually go in and shoot
from the inside from according to
filmmakers so they shot and they made
use out of this and supposedly it's it's
been used in a lot of films but it's
like Gilmore Girls set to no I don't
know I've never watched that so yeah so
he's you know he's in the middle of his
problem and his solution is to you know
get Doc's help so but he's you know
can't reach doc that's true in any phone
books right so that's his first attempt
and again he's a fish out of water right
right so all these jokes here about tab
and Pepsi free he's dressed totally
inappropriate for that time a little bit
suspect right and it's okay to kind of
stop the story here a little bit because
you know we still were still in the
manova problem and we haven't found it
figure out the solution it's a big
problem - so here's ah ha the
introduction of well we've already we
already know about it the Biff Biff in
the way conflict with dish he sees his
father right and here it is how many
kids in the 80s had that happened to
them it's cool but premier is a Biff
bullies always the father yeah and it's
been going on for a while now and it's
definitely gonna be a problem while the
story exists in 1955 you know but it's
interesting because Marty stands up to
him because he doesn't really have the
social issues at stake where yeah it has
to belong to any yeah well Marty's got
other things to worry about like his
whole existence and so you know he's
little a little bit more open to
standing up to this right
but it's still hard I mean Biff some big
dude plus he has all this entourage
that's right most bullies have montages
and I loved seeing them like hop in the
car like that it's kind of like this
lawless you know free-spirited way that
was also Billy Zane for all you Titanic
fans and his first role was one of the
best goons Thanks
I love how he's just so sort of partly
in awe up and here it's yeah and here's
the you know we set up that Goldie
Wilson was was mayor and here we go pay
off on that on that info that we know
about his look is priceless here and
where he's just just feels like his life
is like flashing before his eyes right
and you see too with Goldie that he's
you know he has beliefs and he's you
know very passionate about things you
could see he right so you already see
that Marty's kind of changing history a
little bit I mean you know he was always
gonna be mayor but maybe he gives them
more confidence that he's gonna you know
he's gonna do it we're about to get to
the next problem
do you member what it is the mom yes mom
he's going to intervene with his dad his
mom told the story about meeting the dad
when the dad almost got run over by her
father
Marty intervenes binoculars would really
be changing by a window like I'm sorry I
think that's how I change oh oh really
okay yeah here we go
this is the dad all the way Marty
intervenes with this with the dad's fate
Julian just takes off right George just
takes off shows that he is and there's
an even bigger problem which is that
which we will find out in a couple
minutes that the mother likes him yes
instead of the father
she's very intrigued by him because he's
not like the other right other boys in
the neighborhood here she's using her
like motherly voice but then it changes
when she went through your real life
she's you know teenager right
they're in her room and it's perfect
1950s room right if you notice in the
background by the mirrors over there
it's kind of hard to tell but maybe if
you have the blu-ray you could see that
those are all like heartthrobs from the
1950s so she's kind of a little boy
crazy right but she plays a really like
innocently that I think that probably
didn't come across on you know on paper
that it was probably probably read a
little bit dirtier but you know she's
still a good girl yeah yeah she plays
like very innocently right she's not a
beatnik at that time which was like hey
so problem is that now the mom likes
Barney
oh this is the same reason is tidy what
yep yes sorry I remember this look at
this physical physical right yep
tripping yep falling the filmmaker said
he could do that on every take so and
that's the mom right perfect 1950s mom
there's the television set
a perfect family dinner
oh yeah Jason and Herbie yeah yeah the
older brother from the one years and was
that joke about he said those Joey being
behind bars car serrated huh you know
the scene is kind of slow but we're
still able to get away with it because
he still hasn't been he hasn't been able
to find doc yet you know so we're still
there's still something kind of left you
know you you know still on the table you
know yeah it sets up sort of the safety
and domestication of that time and just
the innocence right but one thing is
that if you know if all these problems
were solved and we were watching this
we'd be kind of a boring scene but
because there's still stuff left up in
the air we're still we're gonna still be
engaged in watching this you know right
there's that scene from the honeymooners
oh yeah man from space there's the
precocious little brother says how would
you know this he rerun it's a rerun
so he's uncomfortable yeah he's trying
to make it seem like everything's fine
it's always awkward going to other
families family dinners I can reveal the
awkwardness of that these are whose
grandparents but at a younger age weird
are you using the right fork what if you
put your elbows on the table I mean this
film has a lot of you know great comedic
moments like you know but it's also like
a good blend of action adventure and
romance you know it's kind of ways all
those pretty well you know a likeable
hero you know you want to root for for
Marty right and I think we get that from
right here they you know setting up
Marty's life and we see him you know you
have to first like your character before
you kind of get on board with with what
their conflict is what they want you
know yeah it had it been Biff and we
took a day through this like right
probably wouldn't feel anything the same
for them right and also we hate Biff so
right alright so this is uh you know
he's still trying to find doc and he
finally found him I love Doc's place so
the solution to his problem would be to
get Doc's help
how will doc believe him right so he
found him that's good
and here we see doc during better times
maybe
well better financially but he still
hasn't invented anything that works but
he in briefs he doesn't question Marty
no no he sees he's also like he yet he
also just hit his head - if you see the
bandage right there and you know the
story about how he he just came up with
the flux capacitor so he's a little he's
eccentric but he's also you know heard
himself - great physical comedy right
there yeah again that's weird I think I
heard that Christopher Lloyd didn't
necessarily want to take the role at
first oh I don't I don't know about that
okay so skin then he finally got on
board so here's another problem so he
finally he's we got dots you know we
found doc but doc does not believe Marty
that's a problem I mean why would you
believe that you invented a time machine
and and someone's from the future I mean
makes more sense as a practical joke you
know
sure candid camera so the question is
this is a problem how is he gonna get
him to you know believe him so he's he's
showing this is the first attempt you
showing this picture and stock duck
still doesn't believe him
so he tells them who the president is
and that really makes him not believe
him
Ronald Reagan love that joke by the way
so how is he gonna do it all you're
gonna see right in about two seconds so
this is the part of the conflict where
no one's believing him right but he just
got his solution which is flux capacitor
now all of a sudden he's on board
but he's got to see it to believe it so
he heard the story and now he's got a
he's got a witness his invention
I love those going doors I love that
it's like a stormy sort of night - adds
to the stakes right
so he finally realizes he said she's
he's like I made this thing and then oh
no we got a we got to bring you home you
know it's really important that we do
which also helps the likeability of doc
because you realize that he's open to
believing that right right
this was his creation he just met him
but he really could be cares about
mm-hmm yeah so of course we just got a
solution now we're about to get another
problem and he's showing him footage too
right from the right camcorder this was
actually a not a real black-and-white TV
they had to put a color TV in there
because they couldn't hook it up to the
camcorder oh I had to put a real color
TV in there in this box that was from
the 50s and make it all black and white
that's cool
so here's the big problem and you can
see it on Doc's face he needs a ton of
electricity that homely plutonium or a
bolt of lightning can give you aha we're
just gonna have another tie-ins
I love how it sets up all these little
clues right about the film that's great
so here the pictures that we sell in the
beginning
and what was Doc's claim to fame in the
beginning do we know what or sort of
what he was sort of known for I mean he
has a truck that says like 24-hour
science scientist that's what he was
doing but he hadn't invented anything
big yet so here's where we figure out
what the solution is
he just says a bolt of lightning
so I'm writing use the Clocktower use
the Clocktower you know a lot of films a
lot of stories you have the main
character who's got this problem got
this goal and they're trying to you know
they're trying to go through a trial and
error try to figure out what the
solution is here they just give you the
solution you know you know 54 minutes in
and there's still a huge chunk left I
mean the reason why
the reason why it's still interesting is
because we have all these other
conflicts that we have to go through
next Saturday night
I love his place too
like it looks like you would think he
lives there right sort of mysterious so
here he's talking about what's that
steak you really he's saying you really
can't go out
you're gonna affect time this is very
important the story you know these are
the consequences so he's you know he's
warning him right here
he's almost like an expert too because
well he is he's saying things that
actually I don't know if Marty totally
realized you know he wants to meet his
parents but at the same time he could be
affecting his own birth right so he took
he gave him that advice but it's already
too late so this is our other problem
and we see it with the photograph that
his existence is in jeopardy and we go
back to this photograph a lot and it's a
really good tool for when you write your
screenplay for filmmakers to keep
reminding people what the keep reminding
the audience what the stakes are and
every time you go back to the photo
someone's heads come off or someone's
you know more disappeared and you'll see
that a couple times here in this film
you know it's gonna go to the high
school halls so that's the problem right
and the solution is that now he's got to
introduce his parents
you see Strickland again oh yeah what
does a problem of course which is that
his dad's a loser who would love him and
his mother another life is is you know
infatuated with Marty not the new guy
mom likes Marty so he's got to introduce
his parents his dad's a loser and his
mom already has eyes for someone else
I love the 50's move that's like the arm
on the locker and I love the dock is
like this observer he's kind of stunned
right but he's fascinated at the same
time cuz he's basically seeing his own
creation and the effects of it did they
ever do a movie just about doc and his
backstory um the third movie really well
not his Baxter but the third movies
really focuses more on Doc there were
three of them uh yeah it better not be
another runner but not everyday keep
it's just three precious don't spoil so
this is a big problem of how do you hook
up your parents and here's the solution
chant MIT under the sea
does she act edition the dance sir does
she end up asking him to the dance
his mother yeah yes so that's also
another problem mother eventually later
on asks Marty to dance so now he's gotta
go you know which is interesting it ties
back to the beginning when she said
isn't that horrible
so you're right at a time there's not
another clue right so she's going
against what she said but yeah so now
he's you know he's trying to get his
father to ask ask out lorraine hoping
that that'll spark some sort of
chemistry and he won't you know
disappear into nothing you know here's
where he says he's a writer right and he
doesn't want to show it to anybody
because he's afraid people won't like it
Crispin's got great like facial
expressions right yeah he's he's also a
good physical comedian too yeah good
great like sort of social anxiety and
nervousness like it maybe we have
another problem about to happen right
there hmm if not only bullies the father
but he's also has no problem doing it to
the mother so he's gonna get me getting
in the way of things and there's Marty
and yeah so the solution to that one
which I won't write is that Marty you
know pulls him off but the nets and then
another problem and now they're gonna
fight and then this is the solution
right here that Strickland comes in kind
of saves the day a little bit so kind of
hold off on the fighting for a bit but
he also then becomes sort of now under
the watchful eye even more right so this
is all kind of getting a little worse
problem wise you know as a writer you
want to kind of escalate your problems
make them a little bit bigger a little
bit worse you really want to be not too
kind to your main characters you know so
here's another problem to that there's
resistance from the dad he doesn't want
to do it you know so you know not only
do the parents you know the mom has to
say yes but the dad also has to actually
ask and big problem here's the dad is
refusing problem is he's not gonna go
along with it so what you know what do
you do if if your dad won't ask out your
mom to the dance and the solutions gonna
be right here and check out this picture
right here that more of his brother has
disappeared that's that's another
indication of the stakes and accounts
and things getting worse so this is the
solution right here
and again we don't see everything right
away but just a little bit of a tease we
see the cassette and then we see the
reveal right here the 80s Walkman so I'm
writing use the solution is he's using
he uses an alien on his father to
convince him to or to make him a scout
Lorraine and of course his father
believes it this was set up earlier by
the scene when he crashes into the
farmhouse you know and you know the barn
I should say and the fear at that time
of sort of the fear and fascination of
people from another planet aru's so this
so yeah so one one problem solved now
now his dad is totally on board
there's a mini scene example of a
problem solution right there and prom
quick solution
also here's a small problem
his dad is not a smooth guy he doesn't
even know what to say so that's a bit of
a problem but Marty comes Marty comes up
and gives him a solution he just tells
him what to say and he writes it down I
love the physical look of Crispin just
right he's the shovelers almost up
shirts hanging out
awkward poses so this is good
he's uh he's told him what to say his
dad's on board now all we got to do is
wait for the mother to hopefully say yes
what could go wrong golde in the
background dancing right having fun
Goldie's dancing everything's fine
alright get me a chocolate malt or
whatever he says it seems to have
swagger and confidence comes over I just
have a little crush on Lorraine's friend
was she in little darkness was she in
the movie little darlings with Kristy
McNichol uh I don't know oh hey she kind
of look like the girl yeah it's a great
movie by the way happens if you're into
80s movies oh you don't little darlings
just a side note people I'm sorry yeah
it's a great camp eighties camp movies
were big for a while and here we go so
yeah here's another problem I mean of
course everything would be fine if if
not for
oh this
Biff is in the way so what's a person to
do what's this how do you how do you
handle this problem yeah it's coming up
right there right yeah Marty trips Biff
but that's another problem because Biff
Biff is a big dude and he wants to fight
an es so that's yes that's a that's
another thing really quick so Biff wants
to fight and so his solution is just to
punch him and flee and this is where he
sort of invents this game or he invents
the skateboard as he does this rides it
effortlessly he's got the cool converse
on two suns right these guys they don't
know what to make of him
and sparks the livers so I wrote under
the yellow if wants to fight and I wrote
a solution from Marty is to punch him
and face and get the heck out of there
and Laraine loves it right so if you
notice that these solutions lead to
bigger problems so sure it takes care of
you know Biff getting in the way but
eventually you'll see at the end of the
scene his mom likes him even more we
don't want that again great physical
physicality right so and even this is
another problem Biff is now in the car
he got in the car so and and he's now
he's cornered what is he what is he
gonna do if got him in the car
solution right here jumps over everybody
and lets them crash into him a newer
truck of course and it dumps right into
the convertible right perfect timing
that's great I wrote solution is jumps
over car and there's Goldie Goldie comes
and but we got another problem
like I said well now now he's marked
yeah so he's he's a marked man hmm and
it was a public display so they've got
to redeem themselves right here
his mom likes him even more and she's in
full stalker mode right now so this is
now we're gonna go to the green post it
cuz this is where you know we've we've
played around with these other conflicts
but this is where Doc's death starts to
come on in so doc starts to realize
something's very wrong with that
videotape
so if you see right here here's the
problem doc is refusing the information
Marty wants to tell them and doxxing no
I do not tell me so so doc is is the
opposition to Marty's goal Marty wants
to tell them and Doc's saying no don't
tell me and we're gonna use the small
post-it small blue posted last time we
were here we we had the solution you
know we figured out we wanted to use the
clock tower as our solution now this
here is just all set up it's just a plan
just going over the plan so I'm going to
write down setup showing the plan and
really the so really the purpose of
these scenes is just to show what's
supposed to happen so we can kind of
appreciate the differences because it
never happens the way that they you know
in movies when they go over the plan it
never happens so something always
different happens so now you know in the
in the finale when we see a tree fall on
a cable you know we know what that means
we know that there's supposed to be a
cable connected to clock tower and we
know it from the scene also it gives us
a little break from from the other
conflicts cuz we've been spending so
much time doing doing this right here
and it's great to see doc in his element
right you see the scientists in him come
out and write it just so meticulous
about all those little details right the
cars on fire
that's not good the cars on fire and
boom
so more conflict yeah it's a joke but
it's kind of like it shows you that this
could be dangerous potentially but it
they kind of disguise it as a little
joke and we're about to enter another
problem
knock on the door I've gotta hide the
car they gotta hide the car because it's
it's the mother and what I wrote on here
is that she's about to ask him to the
dance problem mom asks Marty to the
dance and that's a huge problem because
this is the dance that the parents fall
in love at so so that's not good
I like the awkwardness - of their body
French it's great right again doc is
observing sorry and she's doing exactly
what she said Yeah right not to do you
know she doesn't like women who could do
that so it's great it ties back into the
opening of the film and establishes more
of sort of his home life she's making a
move on him because he you know he
protected his his dad but then now she
likes some more you know so the big
question is if they're going to the
dance
what's the solution it's coming up right
here in this scene so did so they come
up with a plan to stage a fight where
the father protects the mother against
Marty so the solution is the dad the dad
saving mom plan
and I love to that this is taking place
while he's like hanging laundry out
right right it's great like sort of
filler activity I see this is a problem
- it's that Marty's got a you know hit
on his his mother he's got to be all
aggressive with her and you know he
doesn't want to do it obviously but it's
all part of the plan and he's got to do
what he's got to do to not disappear you
know that's some major stuff so yeah
he's got a play sort of this bad guy
right and obviously remember what we
said about plans they don't happen the
way that they're presented here this is
ideally what happens but they're not
it's not going to happen this way
it gives some jocks old advice so new
scene and the emergence of or we go back
to this problem of Doc's death again so
you'll see Marty's gonna try to tell him
and the problem is that doc is really
adamant about not knowing he's really
gonna refuse the information again some
writing problem is doc refuses again and
what's the reason he doesn't want to
know because he's seen how bad Marty's
Marty has messed up his fate with his
parents so he said I don't want to do
that if I'm the more the less I know the
better
so this is a big problem Marty really
really wants him to know because his
life is at stake so what's he gonna do
so look he's really even more than the
last scene he's really you know strong
and firm about this do not tell me and
here's the solution Marty's gonna write
a letter and just hope that maybe doc
will change his mind and be just curious
about it and read it one day I left to
that it takes place in a late-night
diner like right how many I would always
love to do that there's not that many
late-night diners where you can just
like right sit didn't do something like
that fifty is a great location mm-hmm do
not open until 1985 that's the solution
Marty's letter
so here he goes he's got the letter and
he hides it because he knows that if he
gives him a letter doxa to refuse it so
we still don't know though what's gonna
happen if Doc's gonna read it or not so
it's not it's not a perfect solution not
yet here that's got to be convinced you
know
so here is the dance
so we get a little set up on the dance
and now this is gonna be our next
problem
so you could already see marty is kind
of struggling right here he's got a hit
on his mom but it's really not something
to and she looks like she's you know she
wouldn't mind if he know so this is not
good so I wrote here the problem is
Marty can't do it and eventually you'll
see that mom does it for him mom kisses
him I love the old flask is that a flask
or a bottle
yeah flask rates so she's doing all it's
again just doing all the things that she
said you know I don't know she's doing
she's doing stuff that will lead to you
know her drinking later in life you know
she's totally way different than we
thought she was you know or that he
thought she was right Oh weren't you
smoking - right
now is this where we see Chuck Berry
yeah that's uh well supposedly as Marvin
berry his his cousin oh okay so a little
nod to Chuck Berry mm-hmm so dad now
it's time oh oh dang oh there was no
removed her jacket it's go time and he
really doesn't it you just seen his body
like she really doesn't want to do it
right I can see where maybe Disney would
have trouble with this part Yeah right
right now Marty were in this problem
right here so what's the you know what's
the solution
yeah this was maybe the plan that he
wasn't expecting right turned on him a
little well the solution is also the
problem here it's that that um it's a
little bit of a cheat because he doesn't
do anything but right here when she
kisses him the mom is disgusted so he
doesn't do anything she feels rejected
but now she just feels like oh this is
gross you know he he looks terrified so
she doesn't know what's going on she's
mad I was like this is gross
so that kind of gets him out of it now
the mom is no longer interested in Marty
but will she'd be interested in the
father and here's another problem boom
there we go oh here he is back
Biff Biff wants revenge and here's
another problem if is about to salt the
mother right here and we got another
problem
Marty it's gonna be stuck in a trunk the
band helps them out and gets rid of
these guys so the band is part of the
solution the band chases the goons away
broke down van chases goons but that
still doesn't get him out of the trunk
so what's what's gonna happen I mean
Lorraine is still in trouble here's our
solution right here it's George
but we don't really know if he's going
to be the solution I mean he's such a
coward in the beginning he has to make a
really big choice here so the dad stops
the assault that's that's the solution
but of course that creates another
problem which is that Biff is now going
to fight the dad problem is if Biff
fights dad right here but we got a
solution coming up
the band is gonna open up that trunk
right there
of course that leads to another problem
band opens trunk this is a big problem
right here even the mother can't help
she just she just pushes him or he just
pushes her we're about to see the very
end of the Biff conflict right here boom
the dad punches Biff if you watch this
in a theater every time the crowd claps
and cheers at this at the end of the
scene when when he socks them because
part of our conflict and it's helping
you think that this you know just just
punching him will bring them together
but Marty ends up looking at the photo
in two seconds and realizes we're not
over yet
people are still disappearing problem is
that when they open that trunk
I wrote injured no dance so the band got
injured and therefore there's no dance
but with every problem there's a
solution
look his his aunt his hands all bloody
it's all injured and he's trying to
explain like the stakes what said what's
it what the consequences are this is a
solution right here Marty plays at the
dance but we're going to come up with
another problem with the greatest
character in movie history okay we see
that we see the photo that we're still
not you know his siblings are still
disappeared he's all alone now and now
the greatest character in cinematic
history who just cuts in and decides to
dance so I put the problem is a guy cuts
in guy cuts in there's only one solution
here come on George do it
we're seeing what's but the downs but
the downside is of this goal not being
fulfilled his hand is disappearing right
here we go here's the solution
boom pushes the guy and I wrote down dad
kisses mom boom he's back and that is
the end of that conflict and guess what
in the screenings that I saw big
applause right here lots of cheering
because we're at the end of this
conflict and Marty's Marty at least can
exist Biff is out of the way
Marty can exist and Biff been humbled
right Biff side of the picture so this
next scene coming up is the Johnny be
good scene I'm just gonna write Marty
invents rock and roll I'm going to use
the purple one because remember up here
we set up that Marty didn't get the you
know he did really bad at the audition
and he didn't get that dig this is kind
of a to fulfill that you know but
nothing bad is happening this is
actually a little bit of tribute this is
actually a scene that the studio was
thinking about cutting so they're like
can we just cut the scene it's like you
know nothing really it doesn't really
push the story forward like these other
ones there's no problem or solution to
kind of push the story than the
narrative and filmmakers did wanna
because they this is for character
development you know we really want to
see what we really like Marty we really
want to see him we just got to of these
conflicts taken care of and you know
let's take a break let's let's have him
invent rock and roll so that's why I'm
using the purple post-it right here
and luckily they left it in
the rest is history so that's really
Marty are that's really Michael J Fox
playing or he's he's sinking it I think
that the audio was pre record but he
knew how to play it so it looks like
he's actually playing him you can
already see the changes right the crowd
got a little more confidence you know
from from George people liked it more
got the joke about Chuck Berry here so
yeah I know the film that filmmakers
wanted to kind of reference all these
like guitar heroes you know these guitar
legends and everything's he's got a
little bit of Eric Clapton and you know
Chuck Berry and Pete Townsend any Eddie
Van Halen in there
it's kind of an eddy and hey lately made
reference to that hill and into the
alien scene you know he had Jimi Hendrix
right there uh-huh right there you're
gonna high in the back so I mean this I
mean this film has some great you know
humor is like it really bounces humor
romance we the previous scene was
romantic or romantic and this is
humorous very funny and there's got you
know action-adventure coming up after
this
the payoff they don't know what are you
doing what is this this is great to it
this is you know and the next thing he's
gonna be late and now we have a kind of
a good excuse as to why he's late even
though his character is already late we
would have bought it anyways this kind
of gives you know gives a little more as
to why he was late so he says goodbye
this is a little bit of a weird scene
though cuz they're just saying goodbye
and he'd you know he never said that he
was gonna leave or anything just like a
weird and then he says something weird
about about like if they ever have kids
you know but by this point we'd gone
through so much interesting conflict
that we're willing to forgive a little
bit you know this is at the end right
he's not quite sure what's gonna happen
right but he's just in case he's saying
goodbye and he's saying hey just in case
you have a kid you know it yeah that's a
weird thing to say go easy on this kid
that you're gonna have and I guess
that's how he gets his name he gets
named after himself
alright so now he's late and we're about
to get you know and that's about to
exacerbate a problem that I'm about to
have which is that doc is about to find
that letter and he's got no time to tell
him after he rips it up
all right so this is good this is the
you know for for the writers out there
you want to you know you want to have
this you want to have like a ticking
clock or some something where it's you
know time is of the essence you know it
makes everything a lot more interesting
I mean if they had all the time in the
world then that's actually what the
sequel did in its finale which i think
is kind of the reason why wasn't as
interesting they had all the time in the
world to get their goal and there was
not a ticking clock so if you like this
and you want us to do back to future to
let us know yeah put it in the comments
yeah whatever happened did was George in
the second no it was not
Crispin Glover asked for a lot of money
and they just had to decide to kill him
off so what a min great so this is all
you know set up for you know he's trying
to tell him you know remind the audience
again what's gonna happen you know he's
telling me telling him once this clock
goes off you got to go so this is you
know this is information that we need to
know but you could just hear from the
music and you know the situation I mean
this is you know we're tuned into this
exposition it's very important for us to
hear and the stakes are high this was
kind of a storm coming right right you
could just hear that you know waiting
they had you know Martino's this is
probably be last time you know there
might be the last time he gets to to see
him you know very hug and he doesn't
even maybe not maybe he maybe this
doesn't work you know we don't know as
an audience Cena
and here we go with the emergence of
right here the letter Doc finds a letter
and he's about to rip it up he rips it
up right here there's no way he could
read it and here's another problem right
here the tree the tree falls and the
cable is now undone and this I'm using
the blue one because this relates to you
know being stuck in time I mean there's
no cable you can't go back in time so
that takes priority over the green
conflict where you know doc doesn't know
yet about his about his faith so the
solution here is what they're working on
right now they're going to rope up the
cable bring it up with the with the rope
and Doc's gonna pull it up solution rope
up the cable
this is sort of a do-or-die moment right
time is of the essence stakes are high
if they don't get this there's you know
this is his only chance to go back in
time so they get and they know the exact
time and time is running out
all right there's no plutonium right no
plutonium but this'll mimic the same
effect so all right so here's his
solution we'd use the green one he's
shouting out I'm gonna shout out the
information and you're you you're just
gonna hear it even though you don't want
to but then here's there's a the problem
is is that the Bell is is too loud some
writing problem is that there's a loud
Bell and no time only has four minutes
left
so now already makes the choices out I
got to go I can't you know he's not even
wanting to listen I tried several times
I tried to shout out I just got to go
this one takes higher priority this
going back in time but with every
problem there's a solution so Marty's
gonna come up with a solution right here
of course doc is working on you know
that problem right there of the cable
being undone
so here's Marty's solution well for
these guys it has to get ready for the
he's got put the thing in there right
you know I mean look at the look at that
going door so he's he's really mad he's
like god dammit duck I just had more
time solution he's gonna go earlier ten
minutes
smart
but after he figures that out of course
there's gonna be another problem
everything's going well oh the car just
dies and we're using the blue one
because it relates to him going back in
time so that I just wrote car dies as
the problem
that's still a problem
it's about to get worse
right there doc is now in a really bad
position he's hanging off the clock
tower so I'm writing down problem is doc
is in a bad position and we see the car
still not working look at piggyback he's
he's barely got one of the cables
they're like cables out of reach what
does he do well the solution is heat
right here he times it really carefully
he treats this other cable he gets it
very very carefully so I wrote down doc
times the cable very carefully and he's
got both Oh big problem clock starts but
a solution is about to happen right here
hits the steering wheel with his head he
goes yes very thing yes I wrote down
problem as the clock starts but the
solution is the steering wheel and docks
got a another problem right here doesn't
fit so if you notice there's all these
problems I can't write these fast enough
so I wrote down problem is the steer or
the solution as the steering wheel and
what just happened is the tree is in the
way so there's this dot solution which
is the pole really hard but of course
that solution creates another problem
that the other cable is is now is now
not connected
so I'm just gonna write down the problem
is the tree and then the solution is to
pull harder he's going to get two and
he's coming it's better work
so another cable is undone and he's
about to come up with a solution right
here he's got a rope down and connect it
there's a solution
takes it out of the tree Mardis come in
ah there we go just in the nick of time
goes back in time and guess what in the
screenings I see that's where the
audience claps and cheers because we're
at the end of our our conflict you know
I like it when audiences engage like
that sometimes like writers and there's
nothing nothing well if you have a if
you have a story that's you know
structured well and it knows what it's
doing
you'll always get that reaction so I'm
just writing down here opes down to
connect see this this was a great finale
because I can't even write fast enough
if so many things happen where you think
it's gonna be fixed than it said it so
it just puts you on this like almost
like a yo-yo right right just plays with
you you know plays with your emotions so
now here's where people will say the
third act starts but you know I don't
really think of this movie that way but
but you can if you want if you want to
view it in 3x structure but this is
where back in 1985 but even though we're
back of course has got to be another
problem and what minute mark sorry are
we
one forty two forty two in a couple
seconds see the homeless guy but there's
also gonna be another problem you know
now that nowadays back it's it's great
but you know story is still continuing
and you'll see the problem I mean cuz he
still has work to do he still has you
know he went back ten minutes earlier
now he's got a tell doc you know cuz da
Crypt up that that letter look at that
going door and we see the times have
changed
writers everything looks everything
looks bad it's you know he loves it
we're in the 80s alright now I get a go
he still has time here's the problem
car doesn't start the car dies and those
are the people who are gonna kill doc
they already they just passed him so I
wrote down problem and we're using the
green post-it because it relates to
Doc's death is that the car dies and he
can't save them so he's running but you
know there's a solution right to this
last problem boom that gets shot
he got rid of if he got his parents
together he came back through time but
he wasn't able to save his friend or so
we think
nice yeah this is an interesting second
point of view another point of view
watching it and here's the reason why
they chose that mall because it had a
slope a hill
and here's goes back in time so I said
in with the previous three conflicts the
audience cheered like crazy
they don't cheer like crazy here because
it's a slow reveal and because we think
that he's dead and you know Marty
doesn't actually do anything
Marty does writes the letter but it's
doc who takes the initiative to to read
it but there is a reaction there was
every screening there's like a slow
applause or slow cheering like but it's
a little bit different and it's because
they reveal it in a different way it's a
little more indirect the revelation that
he has a boat from poo fest doc read it
and is ready so that's my last one right
here
a solution is da credit and he's and
he's ready he wasn't back in the garbage
can he I guess he still had the letter
he typed me you know taped it up
and the dogs okay the dog still the dog
didn't get shot oh good so and of course
you know we just you know experienced
all this and it was really fun so we're
gonna have some time you know we'd have
some fun
you know seeing Marty's life how it's
changed we're gonna use the purple one
again okay so in the beginning setup
Marty's life the immense rock and roll
right here now we're going to see how
his life's changed but there's no
problem
so everything's everything's good
he's about to walk in the door right
Sony they shot most of this in are they
shot a lot of this in Pasadena and
Michael J Fox when he was actually
shooting Teen Wolf you know they were
doing location scouting and you know
along that Street where earlier George
was spying on that woman Michael J Fox
actually was like what do you guys down
here and they're like oh we're located
we're doing location scouting for Steven
Spielberg film he's like ah I'd be kind
of cool you know if I could be in a
Steven Spielberg film one day you know
but it was for that film that he
eventually got so that's pretty cool and
and they in a lot of it was Pasadena so
yeah I would that make sense the
tree-lined streets it's right right you
recognize the area a little bit yeah so
here's Marty's new life I mean if
there's there's some plot holes I mean
why why don't as parents recognize him
especially after they named their son
after this friend that had such an
impact on their lives you know why you
know everything that's bad is you know
is now good everything that was you know
everything you you know that wasn't bad
is either the same or even better
yeah like the house is you know they
live in the same place but it's
everything's better you know I mean it's
a little bit of a you know you don't
really care by this point because we've
gone through this whole thing and we've
had so much fun so we kind of let this
one slide but they should recognize
their son but you know maybe their
memories is bad well they're so busy
jet-setting off now now they have this
like new and improved life right right
maybe they just didn't have time to well
my point is that you know as an audience
we're willing to forgive something like
this and not even really think about it
because of of all this excellent work
that was done right here with these
conflicts you know and we see the mother
is now has now changed
she likes the girlfriend
she's yeah there's a there's a lightness
to the house that's a beat right
everything is just you get a sense that
people have a purpose there they're not
just like sort of congregating one of
the TV writers brothers got a new job
and look at Biff Biff's not only did he
not wreck the car he's waxing it I mean
it's finale is this kind of one big joke
but but there's a payoff right you feel
some kind of gratification but I'm
writing Marty's new life on this purple
posted be my last one and do we see him
with the 4x4 or the Toyota four we have
shows that you know the 4x4 is coming up
okay and of course we set that up you
know be in the beginning he wanted it
was good yeah spoiler if you have a
steam boiler five-minute video and
watching this and yeah his everything's
great
you know and yeah and we you know we
love these characters so much that we
want to see them you know in times when
there's no no big conflict you know and
even Biff is lighter yeah sort of goofy
and silly he's not as much of a bully
and that's also a kind of another sort
of plot hole or maybe they're just
really forgiving but this guy he was
gonna salt you know was in the middle of
assaulting the mother and then now he's
still in their lives and you know but
it's really there for continent comedic
effect you know sure
so he's that he got the 4x4 he's got the
girlfriend alright she's still there
everything's good but of course we got a
we got I have one more problem one more
pile I'd when I said that this was the
end right the problems coming up they
can't even kiss right here
ah he's back that comes back interrupts
them look at that going door
all right is this problem he needs them
for something right is that a Cuisinart
hooked up oh no no it's diffusion so if
you notice the the time machine is not
ice cold again and it's basically
because the you know in reality it's
because it was a pain to shoot but
really is because of Mister you know it
must because of mr. fusion in the story
wise his story wise you know he's
upgraded he's improved the technologies
right so this is the problem your kids
we got to change something about your
kids but this is a perfect place to
leave off you know for a sequel we don't
get to see the solution you know if we
see the solution we're not interested in
seeing you know anything more right but
we leave off right here one of the
greatest endings of all time they're
gonna go to the future and when there we
go no all right what year do they go to
2015 ah to uh to help with their kids
thank you so much
film courage audience for watching this
with us we had a lot of fun just really
quick I wanted to just go over
everything if you notice the all the
colors are different you see again but
this is uh these small ones are low it's
hard to read but it's all about set up
right here and not much it happened for
the first you know twenty to twenty-five
minutes but then once these big ones
came in that's when this is this first
one is when doc got killed and as you
can see you know there's a lot of blue a
lot of dealing with Marty being stuck in
the past and then right here we already
have our solution it's the clock tower
so you know they just the film just
hands us the solution but it keeps us
interested in all these other conflicts
I mean we check in right here where he
build
the model but we don't really end up
back until that Saturday which is right
here down at the bottom and the first
problem is that the cable become gets
undone the tree comes down so and then
yeah in the middle there's a lot of
there's a lot of pink there's a lot of
the love story there's a lot of Biff
with the yellow and then here and there
there's there's the the doc refusing to
you know not hear what his fate is and
there's not as many just because it's
it's you know there's only so many times
you could just say no but they're kind
of sprinkled throughout here so as a
writer you want to try to start training
your mind to think of your stories in
this way and break them down into the
conflicts that they are you you don't
necessarily need for I mean some people
get away with two or you know three but
you want to get to this point where
you've got four level well if you're
writing this movie you got four
different conflicts and you figure them
out and you've now started to mix them
all together so I started to do this
during the film but then I I didn't
finish it because it was getting to get
in too much it was getting kind of hard
but I was trying to write copies of the
different conflicts so if you could just
imagine like the green just a bunch of
posters going down like the blue and the
yellow and you know so what might be
easier as writers if you try to figure
out a conflict separately and just say
okay I need to hook up my parents you
know I've intervened what's the next
step okay so maybe you know my dad
doesn't you know my mom likes me
so that's really bad my dad is not even
interested so I got to get him
interested okay I got him interested
okay cool I've you know I've threatened
him you know alien style and then okay
now I got to get him so he's on board
now I got to get the mother involved so
he's asking her out and then
you know and so on it kind of escalates
and develops into a problem a bigger
problem and you know like for instance
with the with the Biff character the you
know Biff bullying the dad in the
beginning is not that big of a deal but
then by the time it comes to the end
it's a huge deal he's in like he's
holding his arm it's a big fight so
everything kind of escalates down and
same thing with this you know Marty you
know he first he has to go back in
tonight he has to go to 1955 and then
all this stuff happens with the tree and
the clock tower and the car not starting
all this starts to happen and then with
Doc being killed first he has to get
killed then he has to refuse to know and
then he has to you know we have to
figure out solutions to that so we have
to that's where the letter comes in at
the end so if you develop your story
like this then it becomes not as hard to
then rearrange him into a configuration
that works and you start to maybe do a
little trial in there and say hey I'm
gonna put this here and what if we just
you know pause this conflict here and
come back on it at the end and we deal
with all this stuff in the middle so
yeah I think that this is um this is
kind of what you need to train yourself
as a writer to start you know you know
maybe include it in your writing process
and not just think of stories in terms
of three acts think of them also in
terms of conflicts in terms of problems
and solutions every problem has a
solution and yeah so I would just start
training yourself to start writing this
way and also analyzing movies this way
and maybe you'll see movies a little bit
differently and maybe you'll understand
why certain people have a reaction
certain audiences have a reaction to you
know the end of each conflict with you
know in this case cheering and applause
and yeah so when did you start watching
the film with a writers eye
I know you've said you've you've loved
the movie since you were a child but
when I start watching probably
recently a couple I think I broke down
the movie a couple years ago no you know
you know what it was it was 2015 I I saw
those they were you know obviously a
bunch of screenings in 2015 to celebrate
you know the the 30th anniversary but I
went to a bunch of screenings and I
noticed the reactions in the crowd were
all the same and I was like you know
what I'm just gonna like start breaking
it down because I'd been doing
breakdowns of different movies before
and I had never done it above Back to
the Future I just have always watched it
as as a fan it always been in my life
watching it from a young age so I
decided I said okay let me break this
down outline style and so I watched it
and I wrote stuff down and I was able to
see it in another in a new light and I
understood why the audience reacted the
way they did at the end and how it was
organized so that's when I started as
recently and what do you think people
resonate so much with this story I mean
it is over 30 years old but it seems
like every generation so far
well actually the writers said that the
reason why it worked so much is because
this the concept of learning that your
parents were once you know young like
you is really universal that the writer
said that this film did very well
overseas you know it was just a you know
it in every country people were
interested in this and then you know no
one had actually really done this before
so I think that's kind of the heart of
the story it wasn't just about the time
machine it wasn't just about you know
before anything or or doubt is really
about that love story that really got
people interested so so did you watch
any like behind the scenes footage or
anything else that sort of helped break
the script down actually yes I wanted
yeah one of the things that I realized
while breaking down the script was that
a piece of tribute I knew was that the
studio wanted to you know like I said
earlier get rid of that Johnny be good
scene and I was always like wondering
why why would they want to get rid of
this classic scene
once I broke this down this way I said
oh okay I understand
why I mean it's not it doesn't really
push the narrative in the way that these
other previous scenes had you know just
for character fulfillment so really
breaking it down really opened my eyes
to movie that I had seen many times
since I was little and it's interesting
because it touches on different themes
like the fish-out-of-water the the sort
of you know these do-or-die like the
ticking clock right you know literally
in some sense right and so did you get
in an actual screenplay of back to the
future and look at it or did you just do
all this from watching the film well I
did this from watching the film because
the script I'd seen previous versions of
script and it was like way different you
know like I said it earlier was like one
of the scene with Einstein was
originally like a monkey and there
wasn't even a car it was just you know
and Marty just comes in in the middle of
it so so it was really different but you
know I'm not really interested in
previous drafts of the script I'm kind
of interested in that what what works
which is the final final cut of the
movie that's why I just I just watched
it and took notes and yeah I really
believe in this whole thing with
problems and solutions and it's
interesting too because the film not
only the film but then the DeLorean and
then the Huey Lewis and the news song it
all became sort of priming I don't know
if you could call it transmedia maybe
some of it I mean I know the DeLoreans
not transmedia but it all became tied
around it and became this thing where
when you see the DeLorean now you think
of the movie instead of what actually
happened with the car yeah this this
movie was so good it's so well written
that it mortalized you know the DeLorean
and everything else you know Huey Lewis
missed out on Ghostbusters but he got to
be in this film and John DeLorean
actually his his company had gone
bankrupt by then and he had all these
dreams of the DeLorean being remembered
but you know it wasn't until the movie
that he really
I actually heard that he thanked the
filmmakers for you know immortalizing
the car and and now everybody knows what
a DeLorean is because of this movie
right interesting well I didn't know
that yeah that's fascinating information
and to the Ronald Reagan reference and
then right Ronald Reagan he mentioned in
his State of the Union address he
referenced a said you know we're going
back you know America's going back to
the future so I mean that's when you
know you've written something really
great you know President mentions it
everything so this speech what does that
make you think about in terms of um you
know here the movie almost didn't get
made here they weren't sure
should we have steel burr excuse me they
weren't sure should we have Spielberg
involved which I know right now sounds
just completely crazy but at that time
you know because they had all these
other films with him it didn't totally
work before and then it works it's it's
you know it was sort of a shot in the
dark and and they weren't sure they
could get Michael J Fox they weren't
sure they can get Christopher Lloyd yeah
I mean it's it's a really big lesson in
on many aspects I mean first of all when
Robert Zemeckis made this he was not a
successful filmmaker
you know he he and Bob Gale were just
struggling they had made a few films but
they couldn't get a movie made and I
mean a successful movie made and so now
he's huge now he's one of the most
successful filmmakers of all time so if
you're a writer and things aren't really
going so well I mean things can turn
around just as long as you learn how to
write a film but that's you know with
all these you know characteristics and
write a film that's that's that works
and also the other lesson is that a lot
of these films that were that allow
these Studios that were rejecting the
film they were rejecting it because they
were going with what the trend was at
the time which was raunchy comedies so
they were saying well raunchy comedies
are you know successful or in the case
of Disney's like Disney was saying like
oh these wholesome movies are you know
are is what we make you know
and they weren't going based on the
material they were going based on wool
what can make us the most money so I
think that's a really big point if
you're a writer is to not try to write
to any sort of trend just to just write
what you want to write if you want to
write a story where your mother is
interested in your son
you know the son and you really believe
in it and you you you factor in all the
you know properties of good
screenwriting make it don't worry about
you know oh it's you know vampire movies
are in these days you know don't worry
about any of that stuff worry about the
script and the story first and maybe you
could be the next Robert Zemeckis how
many times have you seen Back to the
Future in a theater in a theater well
the first time I saw in a theater was
2010 because they had a 25th anniversary
screening and I was just amazing and
then I saw a bunch of them in 2015 I
think maybe four maybe five times at one
of them I mean one of them wasn't a
theatre one of them was the actual point
de Hills mall parking lot
oh they had a big screen and you know
they so it was kind of why I was
watching with an audience but it wasn't
in a theater and when the you know the
chase scene at the mall comes around
they had like a reenactment of that so
it was like a DeLorean and a Volkswagen
I came out so how do you feel that the
script holds up to some of these
different screenwriting teachers and
what they would say should happen at
different points how do you feel it
holds up well hmm I think if you're a
screenwriter one of things that you
struggle with is what's being taught out
there I know you mentioned you know I
mean men should save the cat and I
you've had different you know teachers
on here and everything and you know it
really depends on you know you can't you
can't take everything you have to really
trust who your teacher is three-act
structure from
did not really help me in my writing it
really confused me and really kind of
simplified like oversimplified a story
so I think with some you know some books
out there you kind of have to take it
with a grain of salt and you know kind
of learn about everything but then also
apply it to breaking down movies
yourself like you should break down
those movies and see well is this what
happened you know is this maybe this
this book wasn't correct maybe maybe I
should starts thinking about the script
in a different way
maybe that teacher was correct or maybe
I can add some more stuff that would
help me out as a writer so each each
writer has its own his or her own
journey into learning and I think you
kind of need to take it like bits and
pieces from everybody how do you feel
how do you feel that Marty McFly holds
up today against current protagonists in
like a sort of a light-hearted film well
he something that's very interesting
about Mario's journey is that he's
accidentally goes back in time so you
know the accidental time traveler it's a
little weirder because you know a lot of
main characters today they are very
active in what happens to you know what
what you know pushing the story forward
and he is active but the initial thing
that happens to him he's just trying to
get with her get to safety
you know and he finds himself in the
situation that he had nothing to do it
so yeah I would say that that's probably
the biggest difference you know from
with him and some other characters who
are in film he has some Ben Stiller you
know I always I always talk about like
the Ben Stiller moments in life where
you're kind of accidentally thrust into
a situation where you look like you did
something you didn't and you're having
to like dig yourself out and it's it's
kind of silly it's not totally serious
so you had some of those moments but
more confidence than most of the sort of
the the Ben Stiller type characters you
know because you stood up to Biff right
and actually
you know in this film he doesn't
actually have too many weaknesses I
can't even really think of a weakness I
mean it wasn't until the sequels that
his main weakness was you know people
would call him you know what do you you
know you know what are you yellow or
something you know what you know they
would call him out on him being a coward
and he would you couldn't just walk away
you know he'd chicken he didn't like
being called chicken so that was his
main weakness but he didn't really have
that weakness here and you know a lot of
the great characters today have
weaknesses and you see them in in
vulnerable moments but this guy is just
really cool so so let's say I'm watching
this video I see you're absolutely cool
DeLorean in the back oh right how do I
Drive it and by the way is it stick no
it's automatic oh ok great so how do I
make a reservation where do I go sure
you get a car of dreams' calm car of
dreams star of dreams that come and
it'll forward you to my Turo site ok and
yeah you can rent it out for a day or or
however long you like you know and it
teaches you oh sorry
yeah it's automatic it's got satellite
radio radios from the future and it's
only got 30,000 miles on it really Wow
and it's the actual you know DeLorean
made different types of you know they
all look a little bit different but this
is the one that is the same year and you
know style as the one in the movies so
it's kind of why I got it so does it
have Windows that rolled out oh they
push out the windows they have small
windows that come down and then the yeah
but the bigger ones don't but yeah it's
ok cuz the going doors